Speaker 1: . Now, many of you have been asking.
It's covid going to become a Republican virus.
Is this going to become a Republican pandemic
in the United States?
Because when you look at the numbers, if Democrats
are getting vaccinated at way higher rates
than Republicans and if blue states have much
more cautious rules about large indoor gatherings,
et cetera, then red states, won't it eventually
become a Republican pandemic?
And the answer is that it overwhelmingly already
is.
We have new numbers that Philip Bump wrote
about in The Washington Post, which showed
that the new infection rate in the last couple
of weeks is twice as high per capita in red
counties than it is in blue counties in the
United States.
So important, this is at the county level,
way more precise than the state level.
You know, the thing about looking at the state
level is you can have a blue state that's
53 to 46, a state that Joe Biden won.
But you might really have a much more precise
division if you look at red and blue counties
within that state.
Now, some of the counties might only be slightly
blue or slightly red, but it's a much more
accurate and precise way of slicing and dicing
this.
And the numbers are shocking.
In the last two weeks, on average, blue counties
are seeing 10 new cases per 100000 residents,
whereas red counties are seeing 20 new cases
per 100000 residents.
The new case rate in red counties counties
that voted Trump rather than Biden is twice
that of the new case rate in Biden counties.
That is a stunning gap.
And it's actually you can make the case that
the numbers don't even tell you how bad it
is, because when you consider that blue counties
tend to be more densely populated than red
counties.
This reflects very poorly on red counties,
like the default position for positivity rates
is that red counties should be doing better
than blue counties, all else being equal because
you have a lower population density.
It should be a little more difficult for it
to spread when the population density is lower.
The fact that the new case rate is twice as
high in red counties, even despite having
lower population density, is incredible.
Now, the other important thing is the Delta
variant, which is significantly more contagious.
The Delta variant is affecting the whole country,
red and blue states, red and blue counties,
everybody.
Everybody's affected by the delta variant.
But if you consider and compare counties today
versus where they were a year ago, meaning
not only pre Delta but pre vaccine, we are
basically seeing the same partizan split on
average.
You see even even consider it comparing to
a year ago, you are seeing dramatically worse
numbers in the red counties than in the blue
counties.
Now, the immediate question is, Will, how
how is the Trump electorate going to react?
How are the Trump people going to react?
Well, they're already doing it.
They are saying the statistics are fake to
make them look bad.
Now, that, of course, would require all sorts
of conspiracy involving a whole bunch of different
agencies in multiple states, red and blue
states.
The simpler explanation, a sort of casual
Occam's razor, is the data might just be real
and it reflects what's happening within these
different places.
That's the most intuitive.
It requires the fewest assumptions and it's
the simplest explanation.
So some people will claim the numbers are
just fake and they're made up.
Others will just ignore the statistics.
You know, it'll it'll and it could shift over
time.
It might begin with denial.
Then it will go to anger about the people
making up numbers to make red states look
bad and then who knows?
Or they might even invent something whole
cloth.
You know, Biden is bringing infected immigrants
from other countries and releasing them into
red states to drive up the numbers, something
like that.
But the truth is, this is exactly what you
would expect based on the different behavior,
the different attitudes and the different
vaccination rates.
The other thing you might see, by the way,
the other thing you might see as a result
of this is some of the red states just clamping
down on reporting this stuff.
We're going to look at covid hell Florida
later.
We still don't even know if we're getting
accurate numbers from Florida.
The numbers we're getting are the worst in
the country and the worst that Florida has
seen in the pandemic.
Single day record, more than twenty four,
twenty one thousand cases in a single day
over the weekend.
We don't even know if these are truly the
numbers that are coming out of Florida.
And given their track record, it's really
unclear.
So it is wild what is going on right now.
The world is looking on in horror.
The vaccinated are looking at the unvaccinated
and saying, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
And I have actually a really sort of disturbing
voicemail today about how we've been talking.
About vaccination, that'll be a little bit
later, but after the break, we'll look at
Florida and we'll look at a whole bunch of
other things that took place over the weekend.
It is August.
We are two weeks to the day from the 16th
anniversary of The David Pakman Show.
On that day, August 16th, two weeks from today,
we will be doing a one day membership special.
I want it to be the biggest one day sign up
in the history of the show will be offering
a huge discount on August 16th.
If you'd like to be notified, just get on
my newsletter at David Pakman Dotcom.
Remember that The David Pakman Show is really
a program unlike any other, not only because
I have no idea what I'm doing, but also because
we're funded directly by our audience.
Our program is funded by people like you,
and you can sign up and grab a membership
at Join Pakman dot com.
We do an extra show every day for folks like
you who sign up.
You also get commercial free audio and video
feeds of
the show, if you would like them, and occasional
member only town halls you can sign up at,
join Pakman dot com.